avec ces nouvelles manifestations
aujourd'hui en france contre le pass
vaccinale à paris plusieurs cortèges ont
pris le départ celui des gilets jaunes
qui se rassemblent place de la
république un autre groupe de
manifestants est parti de la place
d'anvers dans le xviiie arrondissement
de paris direction place de la nation et
puis comme tous les samedis les
patriotes de florian philippot se
mobilisent tout aussi depuis la place de
barcelone dans le 16ème arrondissement
de la capitale est justement on va tout
de suite retrouvé un autre reporter
david khalifa dans le 16e arrondissement
de paris
bonjour david alors la mobilisation est
elle au rendez vous cet après midi
eh bien écoutez olivier un millier de
personnes se sont rassemblées à place
barcelone dans le 16e arrondissement de
paris pour a dénoncé le site impasse de
la honte malgré la validation garde du
conseil constitionnel de ce pass
vaccinale est bien la mobilisation est
au rendez vous un à l'initiative de
florian philippot il ne compte rien
lâcher jusqu'au bout pour eux se passe
vaccinale est un liberticide il a été
mis en place que pour diviser le peuple
français est resté uni jusqu'au bout
pour la liberté en voilà est-ce qu'on
pût scandé à plusieurs reprises les
manifestants
je vous propose dans l'écouté certains
on est toujours là ça fait des mois
qu'on se mobilise on lâche rien il faut
toujours mené le combat parce que se
passe est une discrimination on avait la
possibilité de faire des tests avant ce
n'est plus possible jusqu'à où vous
allez leur projet là on apprend aussi qu
ils ont allégé certaine mesure
c'est bien il ya des gens qui disent que
c'est bien et tout mais tant qu'ils
n'auront pas enlever le pass on
continuera le combat là il faut
continuer la lutte je pense rien laisser
passer parce que ce pass vaccinale ne
sert à rien selon moi est que voilà il
faut continuer à être dans la rue si on
pouvait on serait dans la rue tous les
jours je pense ça fait plus d'un an
qu'on vient tous les samedis on veut
notre liberté la liberté de faire ce
qu'on veut d'elle d'agir
le mouvement des patriotes qui se veut
avant tout un pacifiste ne pas revivre
l'épisode sombre de la semaine dernière
où deux journalistes de l'afp a été bon
et et a agressé la semaine dernière le
dispositif de sécurité a largement été
renforcées pour cette mobilisation une
violence que condamnent fermement à
florian philippot le leader l'adf
patriotes mais pour lui la véritable
violence elle vient des manuels magpies
l'on condamne les violences évidemment
mais on connaît surtout la violence de
monsieur macron contre les français et
qui les met à la rue qui les empêche
d'avoir des droits qui les empêchent de
vivre qui les emmerdes comme il le dit
mais qu'il les traite comme des
sous-citoyens ça pour moi ça me paraît
infiniment plus violent que les
quolibets malheureux contre des
journalistes
le cortège vient de s'élancer à pourront
se rendre place bière baroque dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris comme vous
pouvez le voir un derrière moi les
milliers de personnes 1 kg
la rue
battre le pavé parisien afin de retirer
le pass vaccinale et dénoncé une
dictature sanitaire qui étaient mises en
place depuis le début de l'épidémie
voilà l'objectif principal de cette
manifestation qui elle vient de démarrer
donc un pur un torrent droite le cas
marocain c'était trop tard merci
beaucoup david on vous retrouve un tout
au long de l'après-midi poursuivre cette
mobilisation david khalifa en duplex
avec alexandre planasse qui vous
accompagnent derrière la caméra